i did want to ask you about jojo rabbit  because did i hear that you had a role  that was cut from the film  i did and i have to say i am  so related it was cut i was the american  soldier and i turned up at the end and i  gave this very sort of  righteous uh speech  saying how america saved the day  um and then that  turned into um total  uh prejudice um and  racism really toward uh german people so  it was a bit it was sort of trying to be  um ironic yeah we've saved the day  and now we're gonna um you know turn and  be cruel  on these other people as they have done  so it was it was very um clever  but it was completely unneeded  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]